and let's start with a press conference
earlier from 10 republican governors
sort of an alliance of republican
governors laying out a 10-point plan
that they have all come together to
support to try to control the border
crisis clearly they're trying to put on
a united front against what they see as
failures from the present federal
administration and joe biden what were
the
broad strokes of what we heard today
from these gop governors
so the main takeaway is what they're
demanding from joe biden is number one
they want the wall to be built again
they want joe biden to allow the wall to
be built as it stands right now upwards
of five million dollars are being wasted
every single day for the wall to not be
built american taxpayers are paying up
to five mill a day just to let a bunch
of metal
bake out in the sun essentially those
contracts are signed the contractors are
being paid but no work is being done
another thing they want is they want the
remaining mexico policy reinstated
you'll remember just a few weeks ago a
federal judge ordered that it has to be
reinstated well the biden administration
hasn't done that they haven't reached
out to mexico there's been no movement
on that front so they're saying that
they're violating what that federal
judge ruled they want that to be taken
care of they also want title 42 to be
enforced with everybody that is the uh
health rule where once somebody's
encountered at the border they get put
on a bus and they get taken right back
to mexico because of kobat-19 concerns
well the under the trump administration
that was being applied to pretty much
almost anybody who came across under the
biden administration they're not doing
it with family units teenagers kids that
sort of a thing so that's why you see
all those crazy images of family units
just being mass released into the
country put on buses and they're getting
to fly wherever they want um so those
are those are kind of a few of the key
points they also are demanding that uh
catch and release be ended and that's
kind of along the same lines they
believe
what's enticing all of these migrants to
come here to america right now is they
know and this is true because i've
talked to a bunch of them over the past
several months they know if they can
just get here and step foot on u.s soil
they will have a very good chance of
just being released into the country
with an nta or an ntr a court date
several years down the road because
there's such a backlog right now and
they can disappear into the shadows and
that is what is enticing so many of them
to come the governors say you have to
end that immediately you cannot give
these migrants the prize before they go
through the system you have to take away
the incentive to come here they also
pointed out that
they sent a letter to president biden 16
days ago asking for a meeting in person
on the border
and they say president biden never
responded to them
the meantime i want to pick up on on one
of the last points that you made here's
a report from nbc news and you've
already basically confirmed what they're
hearing as well but just for the
audience let's listen together to cut
nine after the dramatic surge of
migrants into del rio texas last month
the biden administration deported some
to haiti but it released the majority
around 13 000 into the u.s to wait for
asylum cases
they're still coming now because of
worsening economic conditions in south
america where some had settled and the
belief they might now be allowed to stay
in the u.s
they believe they might now be allowed
to stay in the u.s and it's more than
might i mean
it's a very good chance as you point out
bill
and this is what we saw in the very
early days of the border crisis in the
opening weeks and months of the bind
administration there were a bunch of
illegal immigrants entering the country
a huge uptick
in illegal crossings and you had some
journalists go down there even national
journalists for a couple days and they
were interviewing illegal immigrants who
were saying oh yeah we're coming here
because biden's going to let us stay
some of them chanted his name some of
them had biden t-shirts
when it comes to del rio and this
particular area and this particular
group of people from haiti
they are saying outright we're coming
here because we think we can stay i mean
there's not a mystery right bill they're
they're telling us explicitly what the
messages that they're receiving based on
biden policies
there's no mystery at all and look it's
easy to see why they believe that right
they've got cell phones they've got tvs
they've been seeing the images on tv of
of the feds just releasing busload after
busload after busload of people into the
public they've seen all the images of
people just being mass released so
honestly if i was them i would think the
same thing really the only people who
are being sent back immediately are
single adult men
or single adult women who are not
pregnant but if it's a family group if
it's a couple with a woman who claims
she's pregnant doesn't have to prove it
can just claim it or they got a kid with
them
they're going to be released into the
country that's just the biden
administration policy and the reason why
we see so many of those single adult
males running is because they know if
they're caught they're going to get
title 42 and sent back the problem is a
lot of them get away because border
patrol is just so overwhelmed right now
you have all these family units coming
across that sucks up border patrol
resources they have to bring agents in
to do all that paperwork and then the
actual agents who are out on the front
line patrolling they get yanked off the
front lines to help out with all that
patrol so just to put in perspective for
you when that del rio situation happened
basically every agent in del rio sector
got called under that bridge because
they had to process it and get them out
of there as fast as possible because it
was such an optics problem well what
happened when all those agents were down
there you know what happened more than
220 miles of the border in that sector
were left completely unpatrolled who
knows how many drugs came spilling it
there are going to be people who died in
the united states in random states iowa
kentucky all across the country who died
of fentanyl overdoses
because of drugs that came through
during that open window that's just a
fact
because our resources and our personnel
who by the way are getting attacked
baselessly with these whipping smears
from the white house they all had to go
to one place to clean up an optics
problem for the biden administration and
then the number of got aways is just an
untold number of folks and i know that
the estimate is 400 000 known godaways
this year alone have entered the united
states the real number is almost
certainly higher than that and your
point about how this has an impact not
just in border states explains why there
were 10 republican governors at this
news conference it wasn't just governor
abbott and governor ducey who were
obviously there it was also governor
reynolds from iowa governor kemp from
georgia and others
bill i want to ask you
about a few other things that you've
reported and we talked a bit about them
yesterday i raised them on the show
reports of people who have been
encountered and have been detained at
the border not counting any of the
godaways and we know that the cartels
and the traffickers and the coyotes
specifically
try to get people with kids and family
units to all gather in one area to
distract from other areas to allow you
know higher risk people to be able to
slip into the country undetected and and
not get detained that is part of their
strategy here and we've heard that from
border officials now for many months
but
among those who have gotten caught there
are a litany of folks even in just in
one sector alone correct who
have been convicted of serious crimes
already in the united states have been
deported and now they're back again
that's correct um look there is no
global database that border patrol has
access to where they can check criminal
histories for people say coming in from
syria or or turkey or something like
that the databases they are working with
yeah the databases they're working with
for the most part are here in the us so
these are people who have been convicted
of crimes in the u.s and have been
previously deported so then they try to
come back and it used to be you know if
you if you were a repeat offender at the
border they used to prosecute that they
don't do that anymore i mean now if
somebody gets sent back via title 42
they'll come back that same day they'll
come back the next day i mean they'll
try over and over and over and the
federal government started to kind of
realize that so what they've been trying
to do now is instead of just busting
them back across the border they'll put
them on an airplane and fly them deep
into southern mexico to try to make it
harder for them to come back up here but
as we've seen it's it's not slowing
anything down it's not stopping anybody
from trying and the crazy thing is the
worst is potentially yet to come i mean
i'm sure you've seen all these reports
about the potential 60 000 more haitians
making their way through mexico
right now am i correct that's haitians
alone not to count any of the other you
know many thousands of people from more
than 100 different countries right it's
just 60 000 haitians in that group
coming toward the border that's correct
and where that number is coming from is
from panama's foreign minister she said
at the start of the year there were once
once joe biden took over there were 80
000 haitians who passed through panama
about 20 000 of them have turned up at
the u.s border already so that leaves
about 60 000 left that are still trying
to move north so that's where that
number comes from and what there's there
have been videos from tapatullah mexico
of those haitians holding protests
demanding to be able to move north the
mexican government does offer resistance
in some areas
but other times they just let them
through and that's what we saw happen
with del rio
i mean it's
it's pretty breathtaking i mentioned the
400 000 got aways that was the estimate
from the former border patrol chief
interviewed on special report the last
two nights
are you also hearing because i know that
it was reported elsewhere that in
october right because over the summer
was supposed to be so hot that this
would sort of calm down and we would see
the numbers dip we saw the opposite the
numbers were sky high in july and august
20 year plus highs in terms of border
encounters
they're worried that in october with the
weather cooling down
that number could grow substantially
perhaps even double are you hearing that
i i've seen the reports that they're
trying to prepare for the potential of
400 000 i mean if that happened
i mean that's just insane i mean
we've had 200 000 over the last couple
of months and that's just completely
overwhelming um i i will be shocked if
it's that many um i think i think what
those reports are kind of putting
together is just you know the 60 000
haitians the cooling down of the weather
more people seeing that people are being
released i think that's kind of like the
worst case scenario that they're
potentially trying to plan for if that
actually yeah because if all of a sudden
it's three hundred thousand like oh see
it's not so bad three hundred thousand
two hundred fifty 000 a third
consecutive month of 200 000 plus would
be astounding unto itself uh so i sort
of wonder are they maybe conditioning us
to expect 400 000 and then claim victory
if it's another totally unsustainable
high growth number bill malugion last
question for you you tweeted some images
of it looked like guys in in tactical
vests with with long guns
powerful weapons
where did you get these images who were
these people
and what are the implications of some of
these images
so those are cartel gunmen in roma texas
they're involved in human smuggling
we're actually in roma right now about a
mile away from those pictures were taken
their cartel gunman in roma texas they
bring people across the river and what
you're seeing in those photos is they're
holding ak-47s and they're wearing tack
vests and they are taunting the texas
national guard soldiers on the other
side of the river brandishing their
weapons this is something that i'm told
has happened multiple times in recent
days and really just kind of shows how
ballsy some of these cartel members are
we often hear
we often hear that the cartels are
always working at the border but very
rarely do we actually get to see them
like that in in a picture holding their
weapons just out in the middle of broad
daylight so tonight we are actually
embedding with the texas national guard
here in roma um in the exact area where
this has been happening so we'll we'll
see we'll see what happens with that and
those photos those photos were courtesy
of texas dps
i mean it's just so brazen
and they're operating
clearly with what they believe to be
complete impunity are they
ridiculing and taunting
the the texas officials basically saying
we're here and there's nothing you can
do about it
it's not so much they're saying anything
it's the fact that they're just standing
out in the middle of the rio grande with
high-powered rifles and just eyes right
look at us
no
as they're bringing people across the
river knowing they're not going to do
anything
and they they stay on the other they
they stay on the mexican side of the
river so they make sure to do that
because i mean make no mistake if they
were to raise one of their weapons at
one of those national guards but they're
gonna get blown away they know that we
know that um so they're just kind of you
know they're just kind of taunting them
a little bit
yeah i mean part of me wonders if if
they did raise the weapon toward our
officials in this country and there was
a fire fight you almost wonder if the
federal government would take the side
of our own officials the way things have
been going um i won't make you comment
on that bill that's just a side
commentary for me some color analysis
here on the guy benson show
that's bill malugen on the ground in
texas roma texas at the border bill
you're embedding tonight with those
officials stay safe keep up the great
work we'll have you back soon
we'll do thanks guy appreciate it
and just that high performance hair
every step of the way it's very
impressive
with that we will step aside we'll be
right back on the guy benson show
you